i wouldI correct home then my real
houses according to his parents Matthew
was deeply traumatized when he recorded
this video he was 15 autistic and they
claimed trapped in a unit equipped to
help him
what do you missing Matthew Matthew was
sectioned after a violent outburst at
home and sent to a psychiatric intensive
care unit or PQ his mum says it was the
start of a painful journey while Matthew
was there he was deteriorating
catastrophically so he didn't understand
why he was there and he thought he was
in prison was he very distressed yes
yeah very depressed actually he just
found it more and more difficult to get
out of bed PQ's are only designed for
short-term stays intended to bring
crisis situations under control the
maximum recommended length of stay is
six weeks matthew stayed for seven
months
matthew hardly accessed any education at
all leaving him somewhere where i felt
that he was not understood where his
needs weren't being met and where i felt
he was actually in danger was the most
horrific experience for any parent and I
was like my whole body was screaming
when I when I left that place Matthew's
case is not unusual
last year 53% of children admitted to
NHS funded PQ's stayed longer than the
6-week maximum recommended stay 29% of
children were stuck for three months or
longer 10% for six months or longer and
11 children ROM PQ's for over a year
this is where the young people can spend
some time outside Bernardin hospital
runs one of the only PQ's in the country
with an outstanding rating from the
regulator the unit is very secure air
locked and behind two doors this is one
of our pods where the young people
access their education this is the
classroom the team here hold daily
reviews with everyone involved in a
child's care to ensure no one stays
than they should we get young people in
who are very much at the crisis
situation what we don't want is them to
kind of to stay in a unit for any length
of time and as soon as we see progress
and we take a lot of positive risks to
move them on very quickly to be able to
build resilience for these young people
and I think staying in it PICU
environment you become very much
protected of that environment
there aren't many PQ's in the UK but
they really matter and that's because
they're treating the most acutely unwell
patients there at the very apex of the
mental health care system but
campaigners say some units particularly
those run by private providers are
giving care that substandard and even
neglectful they say failings at this
level are indicative of failings
throughout the system we've had decades
of historic underfunding of children's
mental health and the models of care are
really out of date so now is an
important moment where we rethink what
the role of hospital and specialist
carers start providing more
community-based care it's a criticism
the health secretary acknowledges there
is a program underway I've put my full
weight behind that program to try to
make it go as fast as possible there's
no defensive nurse and saying that you
know the job has been done by any
stretch I'm determined to act to make
sure that we can solve these problems
because some of these you know this is
we are we are talking about and dealing
with some of the most vulnerable people
in our society I used to be in a
birthday Matthews now out of hospital
and his mum says he's blossoming but
she's angry about the time he lost and
she wants to know how any child can be
left for so long on award so
inappropriate Helen Ann Smith Sky News